Are people with breast cancer more prone to easy bruising?
Um, no, no, people with breast cancer or any cancer, I would say are not more prone to easy bruising.
Easy bruising, if the person is prone to easy bruising, you think of capillary fragility,
you think of a person that is on a blood thinner.
Um, so if you're on a blood thinner, you can have that, you can have decrease in platelet formation,
so you have decreased platelets, so if you look at a comprehensive metabolic profile,
you have a lower platelet panel, um, you, uh, and you're on a blood thinner,
you are going to be prone to easy bruising, so the number one positive people with easy bruising
is typically an elderly person who's on a blood thinner because of a heart issue that they had
and the doctor never took them off of their blood thinner and told them if they don't go out,
if they don't stand a blood thinner, they're going to die of a stroke and never tested their, uh,
de-diver, they never tested their platelet values, they're never looking at it again many times,
people got a prescription eight years ago and the doctor just keeps refilling it, never looks at
causative factors again and, and also sometimes what takes place in this, they're on a blood thinner
and then they start getting into more natural things and they start taking things like garlic,
which is a natural blood thinner, so they're really getting probably too much thinning to the blood
and an increase in bruising, where they just didn't even know they bumped themselves,
so they got bruises all over their arms and their hands, um, they don't even remember bumping
themselves, so it has to do with capillary fragility, it has to do with, um, here are other things
that can cause capillary fragility and such, um, which could range from a person with Lyme disease to
a person with H. Pylori, to a person with heavy metal toxicity, there's a lot of different causes
to capillary fragility, decrease, um, the, uh, delta factor of the, uh, um, vitamin E, you know,
consumption, all sorts of different causative factors of that, but have the breast cancer,
or any other cancer is not going to cause any of those, so there's other comorbidities that are
going on if that's the case.